almost eight years ago beijing bot and i
founded robin hood we believe then as we
do now that the financial system should
be built to work for everyone not just a
select few
it's really simple just press three
buttons and then you already got the
amount of crypto that you want just
about any stock i've wanted i've been
able to grab and
it's been pretty easy to use and i felt
pretty safe robinhood is a stock trading
application that's really popular among
the younger investing crowd so mainly
gen zers and millennials and one of the
reasons why it is so popular among them
is because of its design
just from a design angle if you open
robinhood's app and you open the other
apps for
schwab or td ameritrade or e-trade you
can tell that they look different
trying to convince investors that
trading is simple and easy
is not new to robin hood
robin hood's just been more successful
at making it simple and easy
robinhood's design enables users to sign
up and start trading within a matter of
minutes
its colorful easy to use interface
resembles something more at home in
silicon valley than wall street
robin hood's mission has always been to
democratize finance and so when they set
out to build their app what they wanted
to do was to remove any barriers of
entry that have existed for people who
wanted to invest in the stock market but
haven't been able to before
imagine taking a hundred dollars and
turning that into a thousand dollars i
see a stock going up and i buy it and i
just watch it until it stops going up
and then i sell it let's see this one
keep on unfolding 157 let's keep it
going on down baby we're cracking trend
lines and let's just lock it on up baby
let's just lock it on up and take 15 000
in a day let's go it was really a
wake-up call to a new kind of investor
and a kind of investor that in many
cases was using robinhood to place
trades and trade
not based on fundamentals necessarily
but based on something that seemed like
fun
while robin hood isn't the only app
that's design and usability blurs the
lines between investing entertainment
and gambling it's left many people
asking is this product a little too good
at what it
there's something to learn between the
old world and the new world the new
world is much more frictionless giving a
lot more access to everyone else so i
think that change is happening and a lot
of the
old world applications are still not
understanding um what it takes to be
honest
so we're just in a completely
uncharted territory in some ways
this is a new type of behavior that's
emerged in the past year like meme stock
was not in the vernacular in 2020 is all
i'm saying
[Music]
during the pandemic through 2020 we saw
that app usage grew on average 40
there were about 35 billion downloads
what we found is that whilst users have
a lot of apps on their phone so
typically 80 or so apps on the phone
less than half of them are used on a
monthly basis and so now it's not just
about creating an app it's about making
sure that you get a user to download it
making sure that the app sticky enough
that they come back and your daily
active users or your weekly active users
those numbers are also high
the pandemic offered an opportunity for
older apps that had plateaued in user
growth
as people delved deeper into the app
store the products that proved most
appealing were the ones that offered
something more long lasting to their
users be it a language a new skill or
money
so as soon as the coronavirus pandemic
hit what happened was a lot of people
started spending a lot of time at home
and that boredom really led to them
trying to find out you know new things
to do and the interest in investing
really peaked in the middle of the
pandemic because people were at home and
they had access to their phones and for
the first time you know robin hood
became an app of massive interest it's
been around since the early 2010s but it
really didn't you know go off the way it
did until the pandemic hit
there's no question that robin hood has
been wildly popular in attracting users
you've got more than 22 million active
users on the platform now and that's
just in a matter of a couple of years
that they've built that base the
platform opened up to investors in 2015
so the growth that they've seen has been
astronomical
so i think what you need to understand
when you're trying to understand why the
robin hood user experience is that good
is who built it and we're talking about
the co-founders of robin hood here vlad
tenev and baiju ba these were two you
know guys who met at stanford at a time
when you know facebook twitter instagram
all of those apps were really taking off
and had really established what it means
to be an application that drives user
engagement and really draws people in
think about pop-up notifications or the
ability to engage with your friends so
if you you know invite a friend to the
platform you get a free stock all of
those things hadn't really existed
before and so they really pioneered the
way for investing to become way more
democratized through a very social media
like experience
so i'm opening my robin hood app
and i see a nice little green screen
with the feather logo in the back
and what comes up is this very clean
interface you don't have to type
anything into your phone right so you
get lists of things that you can just
scroll up or down to click the correct
answer and i know it's really trivial
right like you can just type in new york
rather than having to scroll up and pick
new york but those are sort of the
design features that when you talk to
experts we'll say it's just easier right
you don't have to type anything in they
would tell you that that is just again
sort of bringing down barriers and
making it easier for people from a
design point of view to to sort of sign
up
a critical element for robin hood is
making that first trade for these users
as easy as possible when signing up to
most brokerages a user will have to wait
a few days before money is deposited
into their account and they can start
trading
but robinhood lets users trade up to a
thousand dollars instantly while waiting
for their account to clear
[Music]
if i were a first-time investor i would
not find anything intimidating about
this it's
kind of welcoming honestly like right up
front
there's a big button to click trade i
can see the volume
and i have the option to either you know
buy shares of let's say apple or trade
options on it if i want that's right
there for me too and so really what you
see in the robinhood app is just very
little information presented in a very
user-friendly way with a lot of colors
with a lot of animation and that's
something that hadn't really existed in
brokerage platforms before
from data font sizes that help direct
users to what they should focus on to
the snowflake animation that falls on
december 25th robinhood has been very
deliberate in all its design choices
take the cryptocurrency trading page for
example its interface reflects the
excitement and buzz around this type of
investing it almost looks like you're in
like
a video game or an ad for like an energy
drink or something it's a design element
that's completely different from
anything that i've seen on
on a traditional trading platform
there's a lot of these delightful uh
graphical moments where
it's just reflective of almost an artist
signing their work you've gone from 15
years ago people seeing folks sitting
with six or seven screens and trading to
realizing actually you've got your
mobile phone
and a small screen and you can achieve
the same outcome really as an individual
those trading systems the data the
exchanges the trading exchanges they've
been the same for years and years what's
changed is there is now a user interface
that makes it easily accessible to a
broader set of users we're proud of the
fact that we've enabled so many younger
investors and first-time investors to
have access to the markets i think
design's at the heart of it because
the ease of use the enjoyment that a
user gets using an application is so
important
over half of robinhood users are
first-time investors with 70 of its
assets held by millennial investors
between 18 and 40.
its popularity among young investors has
been in part down to a frictionless user
experience
friction refers to something in the
design that slows you down in
accomplishing your goal this may sound
familiar if you've ever tried to
unsubscribe from a mailing list and
being presented with something like this
one of the things that people talk a lot
about is frictionless user experience
designers more and more are realizing
that users are unforgiving they will
drop off
during the registration or sign up
process they will drop off if they
get stuck on a screen and can't work out
what the next call to action is
designers are now starting to value user
feedback look at what users are doing in
terms of using an app so tracking
through heat maps etc what kind of
utilization the app has from a user
perspective
if you look back at how robin had really
sort of created this user interface was
by going you know out to coffee stands
and coffee shops at stanford and you
know going up to students and asking
them you know how they felt about
investing and how they felt about the
apps that were out there and really
getting this sort of feedback from users
about what they wanted to see and what
they didn't want to see and even up
until this day robin hood research team
is really really prevalent in the
company and they really go out of their
way to sort of try to you know give
users what they want but
there's cost to that while frictionless
user experience may be what customers
want some argue the frictions in
investment apps can actually work as a
safety mechanism
the problem
for many investors with making trading
too easy is that oftentimes
frictions take the place of self-control
and when something is too easy we may do
it
more than is in our own best interest so
i've done research uh over the last few
decades that show that on average
when individual investors trade more
actively
they end up end up worse off there's not
a great deal of information on the app
compared to other brokerage sites
and one thing that does is gives one the
feeling that this is not too complicated
of uh
the thing to do to buy and sell stocks
and clearly the mechanics of buying and
selling are easy but
choosing stocks uh
you know analyzing stocks can be
difficult we put a great value in this
country in letting people have the
freedom to do
what they want
and yet we also want to have some
protections
the family of 20-year-old alex kearns is
suing popular stock trading app robin
hood after kearns died by suicide last
year believing he was hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt the worst
aspect of what they do clearly is the
way they're gamifying the idea of
investing
they're taking unsophisticated investors
most of whom have no experience and
basically making this into a game
causing them to suffer losses robin hood
has faced some pretty serious criticism
that it's making investing almost too
fun
which seems like a strange criticism
but
the point is that they've made investing
so accessible and so easy that they
might be
pushing
traders to take risks that they don't
understand or outsize risks in financial
markets or see stock trading as kind of
a game or kind of a gamble and for the
critics of robin hood there's one design
element that never fails to get
mentioned i'm a bit surprised by how
much attention the confetti animation
has gotten it's literally
an animation that comes up after you
make your first trade you think by
from reading uh from reading some of the
commentary that confetti's flying be
flying through the app uh
all over the place the story behind the
confetti is that robin hood used to
display a confetti graphic to celebrate
the first trade that you made on the
platform and the confetti motif also
came up in its ad campaigns early on
where you would see people trading on
their robinhood app
with an app that's changing the way we
do money
now what came to pass was confetti
became like the thing people would point
to when they said robin hood is
gamifying investing eventually robin
hood scrapped the confetti graphic
altogether but it's not like you're
going to see people migrate away from
robin hood just because they don't show
confetti anymore when you place your
first trade
in my mind gamification is so broad it's
anything that allows you to
almost experiment and enjoy the process
the fear that a lot of regulators have
is that retail investors don't have the
knowledge base that professional
investors have and as a result of things
like gamification or stickiness in an
app they'll almost be brainwashed into
or influence into making investments or
taking risks that
they otherwise would not be comfortable
doing but i actually don't think that's
the case i think users are going onto
apps etc because they want to
invest they want to
try
investing in different securities that
otherwise they didn't have access to
and there was a particular stock that
really captured the imagination of these
new investors in january this year users
of robinhood and other trading apps
pushed up the price of gamestop options
leaving hedge funds facing hundreds of
millions of dollars in losses let's
start off with what is almost bordering
on the ridiculousness here uh with
regards to the gamestop trade do you see
a fundamental reordering here in the
hierarchy of who has the power on wall
street a platform like robin hood was
the perfect sort of vehicle to create
this frenzy and trading because it made
it so easy that now so many people had
access to you know this stock and uh it
took off of course what we've all been
talking about a stock which has now been
on a rocket ship as part of this short
squeeze and whether those that are
investing in this fully understand what
they're investing in robinhood customers
with all of their traits like
younger maybe more plugged into online
message boards
maybe with a little bit less in their
account and
more of an appetite for yolo type
investing this all came to a head in
the gamestop saga and
it was the first time that we'd really
seen such a mass coordination of retail
investors online
in the wake of gamestop robin hood ceo
vlad tenef testified before congress he
was questioned on a variety of topics
including his decision to halt customers
buying these stocks and face scrutiny
over the app's design confetti falls
every time they place an order they get
push notifications they're encouraged to
trade um if a friend signs up they get a
free stock on and on why have you added
specific gaming design elements to look
like gambling to your app
there was also criticism of the way
robin hood makes its money
instead of taking a slice from the user
robin hood takes its cut by selling
customers orders to trading firms put
simply the more a user trades the more
money robin hood makes leaving some to
question whether the app's frictionless
user-friendly design was actually in its
users best interest in 2020 robinhood
earned about 75 of its revenue based on
transactions happening on the platform
so that gives its critics ammunition to
say
robin hood wants you to trade more
whether or not it's good for your
financial health to be buying and
selling stocks all day or all week
robin hood is
there
making money from transactions and at
present without that source of revenue i
mean
it it would lose three quarters of its
business basically
now the u.s security and exchange
commission is weighing whether to ban
this way of doing business robin hood's
legal chief who himself is a former sec
commissioner said banning payment for
order flow would be draconian
what you're going to see moving forward
is a lot more regulatory scrutiny and a
lot more regulation to set in place some
protections for these
investors but i don't think it's going
to happen quickly i think it's going to
take time and in the meantime you know
having access to these
financial tools is is going to go one of
two ways it's either going to help
people learn more about the stock market
or it's going to help them lose a lot of
money
i think it would be completely crazy
to almost
penalize someone for
building a high quality high functioning
well-designed app innovation is
inherently fraught with risk of course
the
utility they offer can be regulated but
the fact that they make it easy for
users to use and make it fun for users
to use has to fall outside that
regulatory set of restrictions i think
that that's something that if you start
regulating that you're stifling
innovation
you